Ob dieser Schuppenlook nun von Seewolf, Lachs
oder Papageienfisch stammt, lässt sich für
den Laien nicht erkennen.
In jedem Fall werden hier, in Grafing bei
München, Schuhe mit Leder von Fischen hergestellt.
Denn deren Haut kann häufig genauso gegerbt
werden wie die von Säugetieren.
Damit eignet sich Fischleder für Schuhe aus
natürlichem Material - so dachten es sich
zumindest die Schuhmacherbrüder Koppitz.
Wie einer von ihnen erzählt, seien sie auf
die Idee gekommen, nachdem sie das Leder nur
mal so aus dem Internet bestellt hätten.
Dessen Verarbeitung sei gewöhnungsbedürftig
gewesen, so Florian Koppitz.
"Und sie werden dann eingefärbt, damit die
einheitlicher sind von der Farbe her, nicht
jeder Fisch so stark unterschiedlich.
Und die Verarbeitung ist nicht so einfach,
dadurch, dass sie kleiner sind von der Haut
her und sehr unterschiedlich.
Also es wird viel filigraner verarbeitet."
Dieses feinere Vorgehen hat seinen Preis.
"Also, bei einem Fischlederschuh sind wir
schon bei über 1.000 Euro, und nach oben
hin ist wenig Grenze, also 2.000 Euro ist
auch möglich."
Immerhin benötigen die Grafinger Handwerker
pro Paar zwischen drei Tagen und einer Woche,
im Jahr kommen sie auf rund 45 Paar Schuhe.
Eine offizielle Auszeichnung gab es schon.
Neben der Exklusivität preisen sie selbst
die Haltbarkeit ihrer Produkte, bis zu 20
Jahre Lebensdauer seien da drin.
Und dann sei ihre Ledervariante auch noch
nachhaltig,
da kein Tier extra dafür sterben müsse.
Die Fischhäute fallen bei der Lebensmittelproduktion
sowieso an und würden sonst weggeworfen.
Ein fischiger Geruch ist übrigens auch kein
Thema, der geht beim Gerben verloren.